[Musique]
là nous retrouvons dans cette belle
cuisine de géniaux et nous sommes loin
d'avoir épuisé toutes les possibilités
avec les simples alors les cèpes à la
bordelaise c'est évidemment la méthode
la plus classique qui peuvent
accompagner des grillades et rôti des
volailles et c'est toujours absolument
exquis alors maïté comment fait-on les
cèpes à la bordelaise nous allons faire
deux recettes en principe aujourd'hui
les scènes à bordeaux net ensuite nous
ferons les magrets de canard au foie
gras est farcie aux cèpes donc les tient
pas la bordelaise d'apport non mais
c'est pas la bordelaise
on peut les faire moi je les fais cuire
à la friteuse on peut les faire cuire à
la poêle
mais moi je les fais cuire avec 2 vous
allez voir la différence et pourquoi
parce que à la friteuse quand vous
enlevez ils sont beaucoup moins grand et
igg enfle
comme si c'était frais comme si tous les
champignons frais parce que ça s'échappe
ayant un cancer qu'est ce qu'on a fait
des cancers
alors on met ça dans l'affectif dans le
bouillant
en deux comme de véritables efforts de
0,6 c'est quand ils vont peut-être en
morceaux puis partira sur la grille sont
pas là et nous allons a fait remarquer
christophe à tata raphaël comme l'essai
de dix minutes dont à la ruine de la
lune brillante pendant ce temps à
préparer quoi la persillade l'appétit on
va faire la persillade alors des gousses
d'ail des mousses die dont on a
naturellement retirer le germe s'il est
indigeste ça vous l'avez dit l'ex
président ano voilà et du persil et du
persil et on va faire la persillade dans
cette persillade être terminé qu'est ce
qu'on s'est mis en avant maintenant on a
les ceps qui sont cuits alors vous allez
voir regarder les cèpes cuit dans la
friteuse voyez commerçants bourg super
ça n'a rien à voir avec les sept cuit
dans la poêle alors mais il faut quand
même aller passer un peu dans la poêle
et alors on les écoute on a fait
chauffer la poêle qui se trouve là en
face y a rien dedans n'y a rien dedans
ou très peu n'y arrivera pas on est venu
là dedans dans la poêle bien dans la
poêle bien chaude
la veille il n'aurait pas pu comme ça
dans la poêle quand même et on line et
la persillade là bercy laver les mains
avec les mêmes voilà abondamment oui on
les remet sûrs et au dessert le feu
le temps de le mettre de remuer 3
secondes et honey terme
là il voit ce que vous éteignez avait
pas ce que ça suffit il faut pas que le
persil cuisine il a église
il faut que ça prenne debout là et ça y
est vous pouvez à commander n'importe
quelle viande avec ça leur fait et on
laisse mijoter laisse mijoter il faut
couvrir
voilà on a presque ouvert que jamais un
couvert comme il faut et couvrir de
préférence quand elle vous salez poivrez
salez poivrez
avant de mettre la persillade que j'aime
bien et maintenant on attaque les mains
on attaquait malgré alors voilà nous
avons deux magnifiques malgré nous
allons les prendre
ayant sens pourrait ouvrir ce côté et
épais et l'autre est mince alors on va
faire de ce côté ça se fait tout seul il
faut pas faire le couteau est en fait
avec la main alors voyez vous prenez
avec la main et vous donner la pointe de
la peau la voilà c'est tout de démarrer
c'est pas difficile je suis pas très
gauche chère mais revoilà donc créé une
bonne entrée de quoi la commission
farcissez la patrie de devaux rien à
voir mais c'est à peu près pareil on
fait une poche voilà en fait accompli il
faut pas jusqu'aux forêts quand même oui
il faut laisser comme un ferme et la
voilà eh bien voilà
et maintenant nous allons saler et
poivrer seul agréé on va le savez 2,6
veut subir en frottant toujours un peu
de sou partout on savait bien à
l'intérieur un peu par au cou poivrer et
dessus et dessous du poivron peu qu'on
questionne pas encore assez simple mais
pas non des puits pour faire ce cuir
dans des bocaux comme ça c'est mieux
comme ça ça aurait plus de saveur et
ensuite alors on va refaire suis là là
c'est déjà ouverts vous adore le salé le
poivre et même opération
alors maintenant nous allons y mettrons
le foie gras
alors voilà nous avons un foie gras de
canard
alors là on prend pas les foies gras de
première qualité on cherche est parce
que ça reviendrait cher on achète les
foies gras de 2e 3e catégories où il ya
peu ses pairs catégorique armée mais
alors on coupe des tranches de foie gras
voilà l'étrange pas trouvé personne
hydrophile enfin raymond fin juillet
il faut ce qu'il faut ou est ce qu'on
l'a et après on met ce foie gras ici là
alors on est normal qu'un tout petit
bout on va couper un petit bout pour que
ça fasse tout en longueur
n'est ce pas non voilà on met un petit
peu de sel et de poivre sur le foie un
petit peu par un pas beaucoup parce que
c'est déjà ça n'est pas vrai et après on
met ce fois comme ceux ci et après on
fait revenir des cèpes à la poêle et
mais là on va les faire revenir à la
poêle
bon on allume à la poêle là on va
pousser la friteuse
et on va mrc on va pousser tout ceci on
va mrc il n'en va pas te démarrer
voyez-vous la finma finement la mrc
n'est set les serbes maîtres des coudes
et est ce qu'on veut là il faut que ce
soit enfin le plus long possible de
préférence un peu comme le sait pour on
va choisir lé lan na une vulliet voilà
et maintenant que lui les chaudes on va
les mettre dans la poêle moi aussi
on va aller ça n'est pas vrai aussi
n'oublions pas adam juste qu'il soit
quand même à abu dhabi au départ en
avons cru et qui sache un peu mais qui
maintenant demandent un peu de lui il
faut qu'il faut qu'il sache c'est qu ils
sont bien dorés maintenant mainguy l'a
bien sec juste comme il faut
alors on va les arrêter on va les mettre
là se refroidir surtout nature on n'a
rien mis on a simplement ferme
oui c'est chez de réalville et à l'art
après ça se brûler les doigts ou des
cartes notre magret et on y met les
cèpes de dames on les place c'est un peu
chaud mais c'est supportable par deux
fois par dessus le foie gras en armes
une petite couche on va ça va être sa
muse et oui rien que l'odeur du cep et
puis quand le foie gras vos fruits tout
ça ou du high art voilà et ont repris le
tout oui voilà on referme
ouais même opération pour le second oui
on peut faire comme ça et parce que la
voie là et on referme
voilà très bien en refaire vos chapeaux
et on met dans le bocal attend ses
bouquins vocal ans normalement si on en
fait qu'un on aux ficelles oui mais là
avec deux on n'a pas besoin de rester
alors concédé un prêt avec délicatesse
d'un local voilà on prend un bocal et on
met le côté de la pop là comme ceux ci
le côté de la peau contre côté de la
peau contre le vert même opération pour
celui de hewitt son face à face ils ont
fait ça c'est assez maigre
alors quand il n'ya plus qu'à enfoncer
et c'est dur parce qu'ils sont nés
malgré son très joli ça y est voilà il
est rentré à quai ce conseil on va
mettre à la casse et sud comme passer la
main dessus il est trés plairait c'est
votre recommandé mais ça ira voilà cet
écart n'est pas très joli notre
couvercle est en fait ça fait rien on
fait pas avec toujours une fille qui
nous fait comment la mise voilà on va
bien vissé serré yens oui voilà notre
foi sans graisse sans rire et parce que
yann moix notre maingret farci de foie
gras et de ces deux sets parce que la
peau va fondre seul à faire ça grèce
mais alors on prend ce pot et on le met
à cuire pendant une heure de temps à
l'étouffée en est à dire comme pour
stériliser les analyser tous avec de
l'eau oui alors on met la voix si tu es
là il est lourd je passe pas ma femme
mettra fier pour plus de sécurité quand
même on met la pierre dessus et voilà le
couvercle et vous nous rappeler combien
de temps 1h doit partir l'ébullition
maïté nos magrin ils ont cuit sur ton
illusion depuis une heure alors qu'est
ce qu'on va faire mais on va le sortir
attention de ne pas vous brûler jeunes à
vous donner
pour venir le rechercher voilà les sont
magnifiques
regardez comme ils sont beaux alors
maintenant on va casser la figure
non on va enlever le couvercle on enlève
le couvercle quand on utilise tout de
suite parce qu'on pouvait aussi le
gardien de regarder dans l'alliance est
réalisée en swing et quand on le canton
le gard d'un cancer il ne faut surtout
pas enlever le couvercle parce que la
capsule risquent de s'échapper borne à
le dire mais en faire quelquefois quand
on enlève show louvre bon comme ça
jamais l'ouvrir peur parce qu'après
découvert un petit trou en fait un petit
trou pour l'urd et de l'air et voilà
alors la grèce et bien mode on va le
sort tenté commis sans ben ça ça sent
bon aussi terrible ça n'a rien de
comparable
alors on va le sortir sans difficulté
parce que là l'agressé mende
voilà notre malgré ces progrès la souris
au foie gras et c'est un bib et parce
que c'était dur pour le mettrez vous
pouvez suivre
à bord la voilà parce qu'ils étaient
beaux et bien besoin dans le box loué
alors là on va le lâcher et on le coupe
en quatre ans jouer la première tranche
n'est pas très joli parce que je vous ai
expliqué mon avis mais en omettant voilà
mais la regarder voilà alors là nous
avons malgré lui même le magret nous
avons le foie nous avons les lamelles de
ce cep et nous avons la peau du main la
foule malgré vous savez à manger vous
vous en doutez un petit bout oui enfin
parce que c'est leur faire du mal
maïté et les magrets si on ne veut pas
les manger tout de suite qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est très facile en sort du bocal
on le met dans une cocotte
du côté de la peau une cocotte bien
juridique aux côtes chaude du côté de la
peau et on fait chauffer le temps que ce
soit chaud dix minutes fermé tout
doucement à feu doux sont pas là réduire
le temps qu'il soit chaud c'est tout
très bien alors on peut le servir
ensuite avec déception la version wii et
voilà pour cette excellente les
délicieuses recettes alors notre
prochain rendez vous pour d'autres
champignons sont les chanterelles ou jeu
et une très bonne recette le lapin aux
sauteurs et au giro c'est ça alors donc
à bientôt
à bientôt amiens domicile
[Musique]